the blue chews work they do work i know
shoals
souls convinced me too have you tried
one yeah i took a blue tree you wake up
in the morning with that dick hard the
wind blows and it's like hello you have
that piss boner you gotta get out in the
morning yeah and i i just i need all the
help i can get in that department hey
man
as belly goes out it goes in it's like a
turtle just for seed and it's just
getting the [__]
it's [__] bad dude it's disappearing
and smelling bad i'm not looking for
sure
it's so bad it's just
it's [__] horrible maybe that's why
we're not having orgies backstage doing
cocaine too the turtle don't come out
much when he does he smells like a swamp
[Laughter]
i can't believe my wife loves me i'm
[__] such a disappointment
[Laughter]